the impeachment hearings all over
television and just pretty much every
channel you turn to they were showing
the impeachment hearings a lot of
Congress members questioning witnesses
and to help viewers keep track of who
was talking you probably saw this some
networks like CBS had infographics slide
in from time to time to help you keep
things straight
for example congresswoman Jackie Speier
you could see that right there they give
you all this information on the side and
I thought that was that was helpful yeah
that was useful as the hearings went on
the stats became less useful for example
Republican staff attorney Steve castor
it says makes his elderly parents call
him sir takes a poll of balsamic vinegar
before each question Bobby scaring Birds
here's Indiana Congressman Mike Quigley
check it out
head is compatible with LEGOs America's
number one collector of juggs magazine
considers eye contact to be third base
representative mike turner from ohio
cheats at words with friends holds a
dinner fork like a spear tells
prostitutes he's Steve Bennett
to be fair I do as well yeah
representative Devin Nunez from
California once spent four hours in a
revolving door has the $5 footlong
jingle on his workout playlist gets
physical just to experience human touch
and finally representative Jim Jordan of
Ohio favorite Joker is Jared Leto as a
child father who had disciplined him by
whipping him with a sports cape and can
only [ __ ] when angry
[Applause]